hi everyone i'm alex wein and
this is joint work with justin holmgren
at ntt research
and i'll be talking about counter
examples to the low-degree conjecture
so i want to talk about a class of
problems called high dimensional testing
problems
and to illustrate this by way of example
one canonical problem in this class is
called planted clique
so in the planted clique problem the
goal is to distinguish between two
distributions
in the null distribution q i give you
just a random graph with n vertices and
each edge occurs with probability one
half in the
planted distribution p i give you a
random graph with a planted cake leak
so a cake leak means i've chosen k
vertices at random and connected them
all to each other
like the ones shown in red here and
so i give you a graph from one of these
two distributions
your goal is to decide which one it came
from and you would like to succeed with
probability tending to one as n goes to
infinity
um there are also all sorts of other
high dimensional testing problems
so typically these have some kind of
a planted signal buried in some kind of
noise
and the goal is to detect the presence
of this
signal and decide whether it's there or
not
and one feature of these types of
problems is what we call
statistical to computational gaps
so again in the planted clique example
as k the size of the clique gets bigger
this problem goes through three
different phases so when the clique is
too small the problem is simply
statistically impossible
you can't tell whether or not there was
a point of clique
on the other hand if k is quite big
bigger than squared
n the problem is is easy meaning there
is a polynomial time algorithm
to to detect the presence of a clique of
that size
but in the middle we have this
conjectured hard regime
meaning that the problem is
statistically possible if you're willing
to check all the possible cliques
but we don't know a polynomial time
algorithm
and we kind of believe this is
fundamental that really no polynomial
time algorithm
should exist but we don't know how to
actually prove this
even assuming p not equal np or some
kind of
standard assumption from complexity
theory
so instead um we
often try to give some kind of formal
evidence for why we believe
the problem is hard and this can take a
few different forms
so for example average case reductions
if you believe
planted clique is hard you could use
this to prove that
certain other problems are hard there's
also some of squares lower bounds or
other lower bounds against
certain classes of algorithms
and so on but today i want to focus on a
particular framework
based on low-degree polynomials which
i'll describe in a second
um so these low degree algorithms
so this idea is inspired by a line of
work on
a sum of squares by these authors here
and the idea is quite simple a low
degree algorithm is just
a multivariate polynomial that takes in
your whole input
and outputs one number so for example if
your
input is a random graph then there will
be n choose two
variables one for each edge maybe
there's zero one valued
and you get to take any polynomial you
like
in all of these variables that just
outputs one number
and when i say low degree i mean degree
logarithmic
n and so what does it mean for such a
polynomial to succeed
at testing well here's
one such definition so i'm requiring
that in the null distribution
the polynomial has expectation zero
whereas in the planted distribution has
expectation one
and in both cases it has uh variance
little of one
and so by chebyshev's inequality you can
threshold this polynomial
to decide reliably whether the
input y came from q or p
um okay and what's quite nice about this
particular formulation this definition
of success
is that it's actually attractable to
analyze so for upper bounds
we can often construct a polynomial that
succeeds in the sense
and for lower bounds we can prove that
no such polynomial
exists and for the lower bounds we
actually
prove something a bit stronger that even
the first three conditions here cannot
be
achieved ignoring the one in in red
and so for example it's now known that
for the planet clique problem
low degree algorithms succeed in the
conjectured
uh well in the easy regime where we know
that algorithms
succeed and they fail in the conjectured
hard regime
and this is not specific to planted
clique
actually for all sorts of different
problems
we now sort of believe that
polynomials of degree order log n
are as powerful as all known polynomial
time algorithms
so this has now been observed to be true
in
um planet cliques sparse bca etc
all these problems i listed at the
beginning
and so maybe we wonder you know why
so one explanation is that
well for these testing problems often
the best known algorithm takes the form
of some kind of spectral method
meaning you threshold the leading
eigenvalue of some matrix that you build
based on your
input and
using power iteration you can typically
implement such a
algorithm as a logarithmic degree
polynomial
and then conversely well it's not true
that
every logarithmic degree polynomial can
actually be evaluated in polynomial time
uh it turns out that for these uh
examples that we know of whenever there
is a log degree polynomial that succeeds
there is also uh you know a spectral
method or some kind of
polynomial time algorithm that works
and so this is quite nice it lets us uh
predict
uh fairly easily when various problems
should be easy
when they should be hard and give some
kind of concrete evidence for
um what makes the hard regime hard
and this is uh you know somewhat more
straightforward than proving say a sum
of squares lower bounds or an average
case reduction
and as a result this method is
applicable to a somewhat
broader class of problems
okay but i've written here that this
conjecture is for natural
problems so of course there's some
limits to
the class of problems where this holds
one counter example is the planted three
xor problem
this means that i give you a a three xor
formula and your goal is to
decide whether or not there is a planted
satisfying assignment
so in reality you can always check in
polynomial time
whether there's a satisfying assignment
just by running gaussian elimination
but low degree polynomials cannot
implement gaussian elimination and
in fact do not succeed at this problem
unless the number of clauses is above a
certain limit
but the low degree prediction is not
completely wrong here
because gaussian elimination is a very
brittle algorithm
and if we add just a small amount of
noise to our xor problem
by flipping a few of the clauses so that
there is no longer
a satisfying assignment then gaussian
elimination
breaks down completely and um and now
the best known algorithms actually
uh coincide with with what low degree
polynomials can achieve
and so we'd like to really formalize
this this meaning of natural what
exactly is the class of problems
where we believe low degree algorithms
are
optimal among all polynomial time
algorithms
okay so the first attempt at formally
writing down
a version of this low-degree conjecture
was by sam hopkins in his phd thesis
and so this is kind of an informal
statement of his
formal conjecture but these are the main
features
so we will assume that q has iid entries
and that p is highly symmetric
so for example in planted clique you
have the whole distribution is
symmetric with respect to permutations
of the vertices
and furthermore we'll assume that
logarithmic degree polynomials cannot
distinguish these two distributions
in the sense that i described earlier
so under these assumptions the
conclusion is that no polynomial time
algorithm can distinguish
between q and a noisy version of p
so here this noise operator is defined
as follows
for each entry with some probability
delta
you just resample that entry from
whatever the entry-wise distribution of
q is
and the purpose of this is just to add a
little bit of noise in order to
rule out any of these brittle algorithms
like
gaussian elimination for the xor case
and so this symmetry assumption so it's
typical in these high dimensional
testing problems to have a lot of
symmetry
but one question is you know is this
actually
is the assumption actually needed in
order to make the conjecture
true so it's kind of not
clear a priori
okay so let's talk about our
contributions
so we actually refute the conjecture of
hopkins
and we do this in the case where q is id
gaussian
and so our counterexample
um feels maybe a bit like cheating
it crucially exploits the fact that we
can take some real number
and use its binary expansion to encode a
whole bunch of data
and we know that the noise operator will
leave many of these
real numbers untouched and so all of
this
data will be there
but there's a fairly simple fix so a way
to modify the conjecture so that we no
longer know how to refute it
and this is by changing the noise
operator a bit so instead of
using a noise operator operator that
resamples a few entries
uh really you should use a noise
operator that slightly corrupts every
entry
and the reason for this is that it
destroys all the low order
bits in the binary expansion and
would prevent us from doing this kind of
trick
our second contribution is to show that
the symmetry assumption is necessary in
some sense
meaning that if we drop the symmetry
assumption completely
then there is also a counter example
and this is in the case where where q is
iid bernoulli
and so together these results um
somewhat refine our understanding
of what types of problems we expect low
degree algorithms to be
optimal for
so let me tell you a bit about how to
prove such a thing
so let's first prove the second claim
which is that the symmetry assumption
is necessary so to recap a little bit
what the goal is
we want to construct these distributions
q and p
in this case it's going to be over 0 1
to the n
with the following properties so q is
going to be just
iid and then
we want no low degree algorithm to be
able to distinguish q and p
but we want some polynomial time
algorithm to distinguish
q from a noisy version of p
um all right so how do we do this
so the construction is that q will just
be simply a random bit string
and p is going to be a random code word
from a certain error correcting code
and well why does this help
so there's a few properties of the code
that we're going to need to use
so the first one is that code words are
duis independent
for d um order log
order n and so what this means is that
if i pick
a random code word but i just restrict
my attention to only d
bits and look at the resulting marginal
distribution there
it just looks like um a uniformly random
bit string
okay and so a consequence of this is
that
any degree d polynomial has the same
expectation under p
as under q and so degree d polynomials
cannot distinguish the two distributions
and another important property of the
code is that it
comes with a decoding algorithm
that so say there's some some code word
and some delta fraction of the bits get
flipped
this decoding algorithm can still take
this noisy code
word and recover the original code word
and so this gives a polynomial time
algorithm to distinguish q
from the noisy version of p right so how
does it do this
well it just tries running the decoding
algorithm
and so if the real the data came from p
we have sort of a noisy code word and
the decoder can
can decode this to get back the true
code word
on the other hand if the input came from
q
then when you try running the decoder it
will fail because there simply is not
a nearby code word
so that proves the first claim about the
symmetry
now in order to actually refute the
conjecture
we need to make the distributions
symmetric somehow
so we'd now like to construct
symmetric distributions q and p
meaning they're they're unchanged by any
permutation of the coordinates
and these are now going to be
distributions over r to the n
and we want sort of the same properties
q is just going to be iid
id gaussian
and we no low degree algorithm can
distinguish
q from p but some polynomial time
algorithm can distinguish q from
noisy version of p
um okay so basically we use the same
construction as before but now we need
to do something to make the
distributions
symmetric so here's the main idea
so instead of observing just a bit
string
we are now going to imagine observing
a list of these pairs i comma x sub i
so we're kind of like giving you the
bits in some random order
but each one is sort of tagged by its
position in the original string
and then this whole pair i comma x i is
going to be encoded by a single real
number as just a single
entry of our distribution
and then uh there's a few technical
things to deal with here of course there
could be
some conflicting information if the same
high gets chosen
twice and we'll actually just throw that
out
and so i won't show you the full details
of this
but essentially the same argument goes
through but now the error correcting
code now needs to handle
erasures as well as errors
so erasure is meaning that some bits
simply were not observed at all
so this occurs either when this
conflicting information is thrown out
or if by chance some i values simply do
not get
sampled by this random procedure you
do not observe all of the bits
um all right so that's basically the
idea of the proof
let me just summarize a bit to wrap up
so the goal here was to try to formalize
the class of problems for which we
believe
low degree polynomials are optimal among
all polynomial time algorithms
and so we made a few contributions along
these lines
we refuted this conjecture of hopkins
and pointed out that the noise operator
really should be defined a bit
differently
and we also showed that the symmetry
assumption is necessary
a few future directions along these
lines
we can ask exactly how much symmetry is
necessary
and also more broadly speaking it would
be nice if this low degree conjecture
could find
applications in other areas of computer
science such as cryptography
uh finally if you want to know more
about this
low degree method for predicting
computational thresholds
uh here's a survey article that you
could take a look at
all right thanks a lot for your
attention